nightmares don't compare to this ordeal
more than 150 people are crammed into
this makeshift shelter Saddam is only 12
but a spear for her life before in
Afghanistan it was bloodless and
terrorists like those things and cause
of that we leave Afghanistan we live a
country and we come here and so brings a
lot of problems and in here also we come
it gets bombed blessed and the people
blame on us and now we are in
felicitations they came to this police
station for their own protection all had
been renting homes in the Gumble for
years as they waited to go to third
countries they say locals had generally
been friendly but after the Easter
Sunday bombings some called them
terrorists several refugees were
attacked at home and on the streets
there was some people they were standing
and quindi saw me under the shelter at
all Afghan Afghan and they threw they
stood after one hour my house owner also
he told me to leave the house because we
can't guarantee we don't have any
responsibility about you landlords
scared of being targeted themselves
asked the refugees to leave but others
free lankans have come to their aid
activist rookie Fernando has been
helping them but feels more needs to be
done
so I think the government needs to take
the initiative to inform the local
people particularly around the gumbo
that these are refugees and asylum
seekers who are fleeing persecution in
their countries that they have trusted
Sri Lanka we hope that the other
countries that have been offering
offering permanent resettlement will
expedite and fast-track these processes
so that they can go quickly
some families have now been in this
space for more than three weeks a space
meant for police vehicles not parents
with small children there's little
protection here from the intense heat
and conditions are only getting worse
I'm worried about all the children not
about my only might learn about all the
children what will happen to them if
they get very serious sick and if we
lose one of them it will be
right now the condition is very very bad
very critical situation even we couldn't
believe that we will face such kind of
situation there are just a few toilets
for everyone to use and these stalls are
also where people bathe deportation is a
reality for this Catholic family
they say they face death if sent back to
Muslim majority Pakistan first we warn
save our life so now we have got one
news that governments excellent and
government say rejected people we send
back to Pakistan but we can't go back we
don't have any more time
so please do something for us nearby
Saddam sits with her mother in the
parking lot instead of in a school with
her classmates
actually I'm really worried about my
future cause I have lots of dreams for
my future but after those things that
happen in here I really don't have any
tricks I just want to be safe in their
life what are the dreams I had to become
a doctor
[Music]
it's really hard to leave a Sangha
vicuna Sakura is a political columnist
and security analyst based in Sri Lanka
I recently had the chance to speak to
him in our DW newsroom what would you
say about the religious fabric that
exists in Sri Lanka is it under threat
after the Easter Sunday attacks well
it's the ripple effects coming from the
attack because this sort of magnitude of
attack we have not felt in the entire
history of Sri Lanka 350 lives lost
what you have is highly I call it a
gross national security negligence but
if you look at the entire tax and how it
was done but our intelligence officers
as well as our military has been amazing
I mean within 48 hours we managed to
take down the first cell and also more
than 150 million worth of assets 41 bank
accounts has been frozen and that has
happened and the president has spoken
about that but what about the communal
and religious tensions on the island do
you see that worsening or do you see
that staying at an at an acceptable
level with peace around I think it the
reflow effects will remain from the main
attack but it's it's important that we
introduce certain programs to derail
utilize if there are extreme you know
groups in this society and what really
happened was during the post war there
was dominican demilitarization and the
mill I mean the of the intelligence as
well as there are there were a lot of
issues and certain liberal values that
was you know bought in to the system I
mean which is which has some threat to
the national security you saying you you
see a curtailment of liberal values
happening as a result of these Easter
Sunday attacks definitely that's what my
way I mean I've written about it I see
it in the liberal societies even in the
United States and many other
we're the national security is should be
a very important area and the values
that we introduce from the liberal you
know I mean what I'm saying is certain
values which has some direct you know in
influence to the national security
for example demilitarization of the
northern province entire province and
some of the areas in the East reducing
you know we don't had we didn't have the
emergency laws in but then wasn't all
that done in a spirit of reconciliation
after a more than twenty six year brutal
civil war between the Tamil Tigers and
their and the government that's the
thing so I think the confusion between
reconciliation peacebuilding and liberal
values because a group like this just
imagined to have accounts like this and
bringing my funding like this and so how
did this happen I mean if it was a
country like Singapore I mean I mean
they would have been been arrested but
we didn't have those mechanisms to take
them and these people were there in the
intelligence documents has been there
for the three four years time it's it's
not that I mean they're been there but
then they didn't have the provisions to
get them in I mean I believe in liberal
values too
you know it's important for the society
but it's also important to protect the
people and these are this is really
important we'll have to leave it there
for the time being a Sangha we're gonna
say from the Institute of national
security studies of Sri Lanka
thank you very much as being to DW news
thank you